thanks that's so cool
i love that thanks reddit
[Music]
okay so the following presentation was
created by
wire we have quantified your digital
footprint so that you can see the impact
you've had on the internet
[Music]
okay
this is what happens when you google
haley steinfeld
wow there are a lot of results
first thing that comes up is my birthday
my age
where i was born my height five eight
which i don't think i'm five eight but
i will go with that happily
according to google people also search
for these five other people
haley lou i love haley lou and i love
the movie we made together it's called
edge of 17 and she is phenomenal in it
anna kendrick shamiq my boy
britney snow and douglas booth
that's so funny i love him he's
hilarious i haven't spoken to him in a
very long time
we did a film called romeo and juliet
together when i was
15 maybe yeah kind of a surprise to see
him come up
one section that comes up is people also
ask can you answer these questions
is haley steinfeld a filipino yeah i got
some filipino blood in me
and i'm very proud of it as haley
steinfeld single
if by is haley steinfeld single you mean
does haley steinfeld have a single
coming out anytime soon
the answer is she's working on it people
because haley's i both have a tattoo i
do not
i love tattoos i don't know about for
myself
but i do love tattoos
is haley steinfeld related to jerry
steinfeld that's actually hilarious
no i don't know what jerry steinfeld i
know jerry seinfeld we are
most definitely not related
who discovered haley steinfeld
i feel like there's more than one answer
to this question
but i guess as far as people know my
first
film was directed by the coen brothers
and it's
been known that they had done a
nationwide search to cast the role of
matty ross in the film true grit
and they found me um so i i guess it's
sort of safe to say that i was
discovered by them
i went to imdb.com and according to them
you are known for these four titles
can you guess all before we reveal them
uh okay
true grit edge of 17
um maybe pitch perfect and
spider verse okay boom
boom boom oh bumblebee
of course okay that makes sense
favorite experience probably i feel like
true grit is like an always answer
but edge of 17 felt like
a real sort of breakthrough moment for
me personally as an actor i felt like i
was able to trust myself in a way that i
i guess hadn't to this degree before i
loved that role so so much and felt like
for the first time i was
able to actually let all of my teenage
angst that i learned i had been packing
down
as we do just out and and in the open
and all on screen
through that character so i'm really
thankful that i had that opportunity
um in my life to have that as an outlet
but um
just one of my favorite films i've read
and
worked on so this is a google trends
graph
haley steinfeld searched over time can
you explain
each labeled point no
i have no idea what i did yesterday i
have no idea what happened on that day
or during that time 2015
yeah okay so obviously i had released my
first single and this is when i
did an acoustic version of the song and
i had the best time doing this so i
recorded all of my very first ep um
at a studio in los angeles that i am so
in love with
and i was there recording other music
when we decided that we wanted to
make acoustic versions of the songs and
that uh i wanted to sort of
make a video component to go along with
them and we shot them in this studio
and uh i did a few all in the same day
and love myself we did love myself and
i did a cover of james bay's let it go
anyway that's awesome the keeping room
got released in theaters it was a
wonderful film
uh with some incredible women that i
loved working with okay january 2018
capitol letters debuts as part of the
fifty shades soundtrack
wow okay capital letters uh i love that
song so much
um i love i love everything about it i
love uh that it was a part of an amazing
uh movie soundtrack i mean the the
soundtracks that have come out of the 50
shades movies are
so um so i felt very honored to be a
part of that haley makes
waves on the grammy's red carpet okay i
mean
what an honor to be on that carpet uh
just as
a fan of music as an artist myself
really amazing
uh experience and lip sync battle
funny enough i was actually well i guess
conveniently and i'm very sick and
didn't
i had lost my voice which came in clutch
i guess because i didn't need it
uh but that was a really fine means i'm
such a huge fan of lip sync battle and i
always think they're
so exciting and it's so awesome to see
how far people can take it but that was
especially a fun thing for lip sync
battle because it was live
um and it was uh i believe the voting
was live as well
oh bumblebee released okay i think if i
if i like gave myself enough time to
think about that i could have remembered
that um
it's really fun to actually look at all
of this just in the last decade
everything i it kind of can tend to be a
blur so it's fun to see it all written
out
so below are the first three videos that
come up when searching haley seinfeld on
youtube
and sorted by most viewed can you guess
what they are
um i really have no idea
uh most viewed okay maybe the capital
letters video
let me go i really have no idea um
shot in the dark third one i'll say i
have no idea
show me damn i'm not okay that's so sick
i thought maybe because it was the first
one it didn't have as many
let's go whoa really damn
ah okay first thing that comes up my
first ever music video from my song love
myself i got to work with
hannah lux davis one of the best
directors
i've worked with and we also did the
most girls video which is another one of
my favorites
starving i actually haven't seen the
starving video in full
no particular reason i think i saw so
much of it that day
and then i saw clips of it but there we
go
three most viewed videos under my name
we searched
instagram for some of your top posts can
you speak
about each of these japan
oh my goodness so yeah absolutely this
was when i found out that dickinson had
won a peabody award
i was very emotional for many reasons
one having made a show about a woman who
never really received the recognition
that she
deserved at least while she was alive
and here i am having made a show about
her
accepting that that recognition and that
honor yeah next
this is my this is my first and one of
three tick tocks i've ever made
i had a good time they were really fun
very entertaining
but uh yeah that was again one of
just a few the the amount of tick tocks
that are
sent to me daily in group chats and
family group chats with my friends
uh is absurd and so yeah i end up having
to go on
and find some to send back uh so
definitely like a lurker
scroller it's a great way to pass the
tent
this is a video of me getting my ears
pierced um
which a lot of people were surprised
that i had never had them
pierced before it ended up being
terrible because
i didn't wait long enough to take the
ones out that they pierce your ears with
and then i put some in for the mat and
then it was a long
journey but uh we're here cut some cute
little earrings in
and yeah loving it we searched reddit
for haley steinfeld and these are some
of the top results
that is a picture of me simply just
trying to get on the subway and go
somewhere
possibly very important somebody took a
picture of me i have
a bow in my hand dog in the other yeah
just trying to get somewhere that's all
oh sick
i was going live on instagram with some
friends and some fans
and uh i came across this
young gentleman who was very sweet and
like such a
great fan and he he makes his own like
he paints
and customizes sneakers and i remember
being like so
pumped about it i don't know exactly
what he's showing me there but anyway
he's dope and he makes cool sneakers
oh my god thanks that's so cool
i love that thanks read it okay uh we
went to getty images
and when sorted by oldest this image
from september 30th
2010 comes up my very first red carpet
the premier secretariat uh i remember
not having shoes to wear and my mom and
i like desperately searching for shoes
and i ended up with those
ugh yeah i just remember that it was my
first red carpet it was really exciting
i was very excited to see diane lane in
that movie uh
and i think i did that thing where you
know you don't
walk the entire carpet you kind of go on
and then go right back out
same way you came in uh i think i did
one of those it was exciting
those shoes okay when sorting on
getty images by most popular this is the
top result
oh that was at the grammys i have to say
this might be like top three of my
favorite looks i've ever done
i remember that exactly that was a
really fun night i think it's so
interesting to see
what comes up when you when you google
me it's funny too because i think a lot
of those when they when they hadn't come
up yet
i was answering them in my head as
things i wanted them to be and then
realizing what they were
was not a bad thing at all by any means
but yeah that was a lot of fun